Teairra wat is quickly becoming one of
the brightest new stars in hip-hop she's
gotten cosines from hip-hop juggernauts
like Meek Mill and appeared on Beyonce's
the gift album but what really makes
tiara whack one-of-a-kind
it's her video style the emcee dropped
her visual album whack world with
undeniable success with that album she
released 15 wildly creative music videos
the most fun video to shoot was
definitely
so many 15 nah each video comes with a
host of references and eye-popping
visuals that match her fresh take on hip
hop in addition to her lyricism and
rapid-fire flow here's why her
groundbreaking video style is making her
an artist to watch Tara WAP first
appeared on the scene at age 15 when she
did an impromptu freestyle for one of
Philly's underground rap collectives
when I started freestyling in Philly I
was really young and that was just like
something to do everybody was doing it
and it kind of like helped me to get my
buzz you know in the streets and
everything the video of her rapping got
posted online and racked up tens of
thousands of views overnight from there
she started showcasing her talents from
local radio stations freestyling for the
likes of Meek Mill and ASAP rocky who
compared her flow to Kendrick Lamar's
eventually I was like you know what I
think I really want to take this wrench
the serious so I started getting into
the studio just really trying to like
write hooks she recorded her first hit
single mumbo-jumbo in 2017 the day after
getting her teeth pulled because of her
loopy state at the time the lyrics sound
like total gibberish in other words it's
an extreme and catchy take on mumble rap
but it was mumbo Jumbo's dentist office
themed video that really made the song
go viral
turning Solange into a fan
she also earned praise from Kevin
abstract abstract called mumbo-jumbo the
best music video he'd seen all year
but mumbo-jumbo was only the beginning
Tierra took her video game to a whole
new level with her debut album whack
world the project contains 15 tracks
each clocking in at 60 seconds and
accompanied by its own video each one of
the videos concepts is distinct from the
next yet the whole thing flows from
beginning to end like a short film
seamlessly taking us through the weird
and captivating world of Tierra wax mind
to bring her vision to life tear it
elicits the help of Tebow Draenei and
his team at jaunty home studio and
Montreal if I could categorize the style
of what world I would say it's made for
people who have a very short attention
span and it's like a candy the project
was first released on Instagram and it
made clever use of the platform's free
column grid design I wrote all the songs
in 60 seconds we made the beat and I was
writing to the beat on the beat was
getting made we had the idea what it
would if I but shooting 15 one-minute
videos each with its own set concept and
special effects all in two days was no
small undertaking we said it was a great
idea also an amazing challenge it means
like literally creating 15 little films
that would eventually live together on
the platform but we also wanted to make
it like a 15 minute standalone movie
that we could release on the Internet
one reason why wax projects feel more
like mini films than music videos is
because they take inspiration from our
favorite movie genre horror Tara had
already showed off her appreciation for
dark humour in early videos like mumbo
jumbo and do Renee helped her
incorporate those themes into whack
world like in her video for bug's life
when tiara pulls back her hoodie to
reveal a grotesque half swollen face I
do not like summertime because that's
when the bugs come out and I'm allergic
to bug bites
so those hits make your face swollen
like you had like a crazy idea like
reaction
but then it also bugs life upon my
favorite movies like so classic like
favorite ever horror motifs is something
I see a lot of individuals for whack
world the surprisingly upbeat song Pet
Sematary references both the terrifying
Stephen King novel and the kids animated
film all dogs go to heaven the tombstone
is also a nod to the comedy horror
series being human Sally Malik is a
ghost on the show whose character also
died in 2010 the video captures the play
between light and dark
showing tiara hanging out with giant
Muppet leg creatures in a graveyard
while singing about death and mourning
there's a lot of childhood nostalgia in
whack world dr. Seuss draws inspiration
from Alice in Wonderland fruit salad is
based on the song by The Wiggles and the
video concepts for hungry hippo is an
irreverent play on the classic Hasbro
kids game Hungry Hungry Hippos right
down to the color coding the most fun
video to shoot was definitely
so many to be precise yeah in the final
video for wack world ways Tara sits in a
room as it fills up with soapy suds out
of all my music videos the most
challenging was definitely waze waze was
crazy I had to like sit in the same like
stands for like it was so long and I
couldn't breathe the bubbles it smell
like bleach she had to hold still not
coughing and like not crying
also what's funny is like in the track
you can hear a coughing but she couldn't
often set Tiaras vision puts her next in
line in a series of true hip-hop
originals she cites the original music
video Queen Missy Elliott amongst her
biggest artistic influences along with
other hip-hop Vanguard's like Busta
Rhymes and Kanye West
she also named Outkast her favorite rap
duo and has referred to Andre 3000 as
her quote father from inspiration to
execution wack has earned some serious
accolades especially after whack world
she got a best music video nod at the
Grammys for her visuals to mumbo-jumbo
and now she's fresh off landing a
coveted spot in the XXL freshmen class
pitchfork put wack worlds at number nine
under list of the 50 best albums of 2018
and the Lord put it on their critics
pics list of the 100 greatest music
videos in the 21st century all right so
guys what did you think of wack world
and what's tracks would you like to see
some visuals for let us know in the
comments below